auf diesem minecraft gta server wird es
möglich sein dass man auch gta spielmodi
spielen kann also was wie deathmatch
rennen missionen usw
a
durch meine freunde herzlich willkommen
ich bin total müde ich wahrscheinlich so
alt aber ich bin einfach nur müde weil
ich muss mal 100 dortmund fahren oder
nach bielefeld und das recht früh und es
ist drei uhr und ich muss um 9 uhr
aufstehen
aber ich habe mir gedacht ich mach das
video ist doch eben weil ich da bock
drauf habe und weil ich noch voll
produzieren muss also irgendwo einen
gegensatz an sich aber es ist ein recht
kurzes video geht es und zwar könnte
etwas scheint auch daran erinnern dass
ich euch damals mal die minecraft gta 5
in minecraft blabla vorgestellte von
evans ea hier haben wir in nrw seagate
nick und denic hat mich angeschrieben
und meinte hier ja du wir haben eine
neue map parat wir haben nicht wir hier
clash of client oder blender pirates
oder palm beach oder so sondern wir
haben natürlich auch noch die gleiche
gta map allerdings sind wir weiter
gekommen und er hat mir was ganz cooles
mitgeteilt und freunde in diesem video
werde ich euch doch etwas sagen was euch
alle so von den socken hauen wird was
mit dieser mehr passiert ist so
unfassbar jetzt wahrscheinlich schon im
titel gelesen so riesig sein gta 5
minecraft servern etwa aber da kommen
noch unterwegs einfach mal das sage ich
nachher und zwar ist es ganz kurz erst
mal nur so die haben sie sind viel
weiter gekommen
also ich hatte euch das erst mal das
ganze gezeigt vor ein paar wochen
monaten übrigens toll wäre das nicht
scheiße ich hasste es face com
aufzunehmen wenn es dunkel ist draußen
sonst kommt immer noch so schön die
sonne mit rein als möglicher kanzler
super aufnehmen aber jetzt gerade
deshalb dunkeln oder muss ich die
facetime so richtig blöd und mit den
lichtern und 20 aber das sollte es
eigentlich nicht verhindern
heute wird viel besser mit ihm
vorstellen und zwar mit speed bekommen
also ich kann jetzt relativ schnell
herum fliegen und game und 1 zu dass sie
nicht durch alles komisch rumba und
durch fliege
ja und zwar hatte ich mit dem nick
beschreibt oder mir gesagt ja wir haben
sieben sachen so ein bisschen ausgebaut
und besser gemacht und hab mir dazu
sieben apps bereitgestellt als ich ihnen
geben swatch bord von 1 bis 7
und dann zeigt der medi sachen ja das
ist nämlich worauf 1 hier schon mal
fangen wir direkt an uns was ein halbes
stadium mit dem er sein ganzes stadion
aber wir sehen hier einen spot schon da
hinten ein sponge und da bis dahin hat
das quasi so gebaut und hat er ist
einfach nur kopiert und auf die andere
seite gesetzt und das ist ein riesiges
stadion das kann eventuell einige man
fährt hier den highway hoch und kann
dann hier lang
oder kann man hier wieder zum stadion
man kann in dem echten gta nicht rein
fliegen hier kann man es auch nicht also
dadurch reihen laufen oder fahren oder
so das ist von einst ein riesiges
stadion saßen die angeblich sehr sehr
lange daran kann ich noch vorstellen
wir fliegen mal zum walk on 2 rob cohen
27 wir einfach hier ist wieder so ein
bisschen downtown wir haben den rhein
wir sehen hier da geht's auf jeden fall
noch ein bisschen höher weil das habe
ich euch jetzt mal schon gezeigt hier
stehen teilweise so sachen und da haben
wir hier direkt versteht hier ist los
santos also los santos auf jeden fall
direkt in der scd hier schön die wege
sehr sehr geil sieht alles sehr sehr
heiß hier aus wegen ganzen hellen und
weißen und gelben farben übrigens falls
ihr euch fragt wie die das ganze gemacht
habe ich blende euch jetzt einfach mal
ein bild davon ein wie diese online
japan aussieht das habe ich euch jetzt
mal auch schon gesagt da gibt es bei
dieser online med da kannst du direkt
sehen das ist jetzt auch dass ein paar
spieler drauf und da ist er diese
pixelige gta 5 map diese gta 5 dachte
ich kanns einfach so in minecraft auf
seinem server drauf kopier mit ihnen
welchen plugin sondern jedes teil hat
quasi einfach so es ist allerdings nicht
gewesen und zwar wenn ich euch jetzt
einfach mal ein
da denke erstmals ein schwarz weiß bild
was sollen das sein irgendwie große
erkenntnis diese gta 5 map struktur und
zwar alles was weiß es ist ganz ganz
hoch und alles was schwarz ist es ganz
ganz niedrig deswegen bei hochhäusern
seht ihr einfach nur quasi wie ein
iphone oder wieso ein post-it stapel
seht ihr einfach nur so ein weißes ding
allerdings beispielsweise bergen die
gegner nicht so hoch so wie hochhäuser
sondern berge gehen ja so ein bisschen
hoch ist es dann so da gibt es dann so
verläuft von schwarz zu ganz weiß
damit haben die das ganze macht wir sind
jetzt mal wieder hier in der normalen
web und dann sieht wie beispielsweise
hier so sachen die hochgehen werde dann
immer heller
hier ist es dann beispielsweise ein
bisschen dunkler und hier steht dann
auch los santos oder so also ich hab mir
gedacht das ist eine sache von 23
minuten allerdings meinten ich zu mir
dass er
allein daran die map hier drauf zu
kriegen schon 10 bis 14 stunden
gebraucht hat also daran erkennt er wie
viel zeit die sich hierfür nehmen das
finde ich richtig cool auch die tatsache
dass seit dem letzten video haben die
quasi noch sieben neue sachen
hingekriegt aber das sage ich gar nicht
die negativ so nur sieben neue sachen
aus der ganzen zeit die haben natürlich
auch ein echtes leben noch nebenbei und
hier denic hat eine freundin und was
weiß ich und hier und da und die sache
ist halt einfach dass das quasi einem
nicht zeigt dass die pausen sondern dass
es den einfach das quasi einfach zeigt
dass die sich sehr viel mühe damit geben
sage ich mal also der popcorn 2 ist
jetzt einfach diese highways ein
bisschen wg natürlich aber weiter zum
condrey ding das hier muss ich ehrlich
gesagt sagen weiß ich nicht ganz genau
was sie darstellen soll
es sieht so aus als wenn ein bisschen in
der wüste weil wir hier hinten halt
diese strommasten haben wir haben hier
diese ölplattform in etwa und palmen und
hält hier diese gewissen dörfer aber ich
bin mir ehrlich gesagt echt gar nicht
sicher vielleicht ist es auch das
gefängnis ich weiß es nicht genau das
könnte natürlich auch sein hier dass das
irgendwie die mauern sind oder so das
könnte sogar noch viel mehr sein das ist
einfach das gefängnis ist aber ich bin
mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher und
hier sehen wir dann auch schon ist die
brücke das wäre der walk on 4 gewesen
das ist die brücke wo man einer der
ersten mission machen musste da muss man
hier so langsam mit dem boot hinten
drauf und dann bei der junge die muss
man retten und an sie da hinten
irgendwie konnten hier hinterher oder
weil die da hinten rum und bla und das
digital direkt an diese man diesem mann
isarbrücke dran aber ich bin mir ehrlich
gesagt nicht mehr sicher was das ganze
jetzt nochmal hier genau war der
flughafen das nicht dass wir so eine
kleine siedlung hier irgendwie network
bin mir ehrlich gesagt echt nicht sicher
aber daran an diesen kleinen glöckchen
nach oben sieht man schon dass dann
etwas höhere häuser auf wieder hinkommen
also das ist top 3 und das top4 dann
geben wir nochmal zu fünf also 45 war
der moment was ist denn wenn ich jetzt
mal ein 4g wenn ich in vier gehe bin ich
an die das war dann vorhin bob 3 und 5 4
ist hier noch section also das ist auch
los santos in etwa und zwar wenn ich mal
nach hinten liege oder irgendeine andere
richtung ich meine sogar hinten was ja
hier sehen wir hier ist auch schon
wieder so riesige sachen hier gebaut
also das heißt riesig die sind jetzt
gerade wenn ich dadurch läuft ist das
ganze natürlich nicht hoch da sind ein
paar werken aber wie im letzten video
schon gezeigt daraus entsteht dann
irgendwann so was also
etwas größere häuser also das ist dann
quasi denke ich wird einfach los angeles
los santos downtown werden also er
meinte ich hatte ihn voll gefragt was
soll das hier darstellen meinte erst die
white section also die wii action auf
der karte ich euch ja vorhin
eingeblendet ist halt einfach das was
hoch wird und hier sehen wir halt so
ganz viel wasser und dann auch hier
sieht man dann auch da das wird dann
noch hoch und was weiß ich alles also
keine ahnung was ihr genau hinkommt kann
man dann genau schauen wenn ihr
hinfliegt einfach mit dem eventuell ist
es ja das könnte sein diese mission
eventuell mit den jetskis wo man drüber
fährt das könnte es sein
und da gehen die brücken drüber also das
könnte echt sein darauf freue ich mich
am meisten auf der map nicht auf die
hochhäuser oder so sondern auch diese
kleinen flüsse dazwischen den ganzen
häusern her mit dem brötchen und somit
jetski daher fahren und so dass wäsche
mega cool aber das ist auf jeden fall
der wab 45 hatten wir ja gerade schon da
machen wir jetzt noch mal die 6 die
sechs ist nämlich hier die bude wo man
sich mit der bombe zu kaufen kann und
alles möglich und sich besaufen kann
also da hat man ja hier in mega gallen
ausblick und alles mögliche einfach und
dann können wir auch noch mal nach hier
unten gehen also da seht ihr wisst ja
schon hier unten geht das ganze
natürlich auch noch weiter als wir haben
hier so was wie eine umkleide und auch
natürlich das badezimmer wo man sich im
echten also hier die um teile wie es
badezimmer mächten gta kann man sich
hier hinstellen und natürlich duschen
gehen das ganze nicht dass wir auch zu
viel des guten also das ist diese geile
bude und wenn ich jetzt mal walk on 7 1
gebe es schon hier der hafen das ist
somit das risiko ding auch mit diesen
kran dingern hier krankhafter sehen wir
hier wir haben hier ein schiff und alles
also mega geil ist einfach richtig
richtig cool auch mit den farben und
somit dem stets cool dass ich wollte
eigentlich erst wieder den coolen shader
nehmen weil ich den ja immer nehme
allerdings ist es da so ich habe danach
von strafe bekommen love sie freddy ich
hab dich lieb
aber das ist halt einfach cool wenn man
hier so durchfliegt und das ist halt
einfach wirklich alles eins zu eins du
brauchst wenn du läufst später locker
mehr als eine stunde um von der einen
seite zur anderen seite zu kommen
also hier wirklich alles hafen schon
wieder riesige sachen lagerhallen alles
mögliche am start ja auch noch ein
schiff und alles
sehr sehr sehr sehr geil also mehr fällt
mir dazu echt nicht ein hier vorne muss
natürlich noch was gebaut werden oder
muss aber auch noch was gebaut werden
weil ich meine sogar ist gab so was in
game auch aber ich bin mir ehrlich
gesagt ja gar nicht mehr sicher aber ich
das schon vor sehr langer zeit das
letzte mal gespielt hatte das war es auf
jeden fall mit diesem video
ich wollte euch nur noch jetzt eben
schnell sagen hier was ich euch am
anfang schon gesagt hat und zwar wird
diese map nicht als download heraus
kommen sondern sie wird auf einem server
veröffentlicht werden der dann von nick
gehostet wird
ihr findet allerdings in der
beschreibung zu nick zu dieser map zu
der online web und so weiter und es ist
dann auch so dass man auf diesem server
auf diesem minecraft gta server wird es
möglich sein dass man auch gta spielmodi
spielen kann also was wie deathmatch
rennen missionen und so weiter also das
wird megageil da werden dann mega viele
slots drauf sein man kann das darauf
zocken es wird die komplette map zu
erkunden geben alles mögliche aber noch
nicht jetzt sondern erst einen halben
bis einem jahr also bis dahin müsst ihr
noch alle überleben irgendwie bis das
ganze jahr online ist es ist richtig
geil also da freue ich mich richtig
darauf freue ich mich mega tochter werde
ich wahrscheinlich dass let's play
vormachen mal schauen wie es dann
ankommt
ich bin damit meinem mund zu gequasselt
es ist ruhig muss um 9 uhr aufstehen
sechs stunden ich hoffe ich kann das
video gefallen ich hoffe ich habe alle
informationen oder gebracht ich
rüberbringen wollte ich hatte mit liegt
darüber gestaltet hätte mir halt gesagt
die paar sachen sind sie dazu gekommen
was haltet ihr davon wenn ich eventuell
mal so ab und zu sein neues update video
hiervon mache wie weit die leute
gekommen sind wenn ihr auf den server
geht und jetzt schon erwartet dass man
jetzt schon was zocken kann
die sind zurzeit noch am bauen also das
wird erst später möglichkeit sein wie
gesagt in einem halben bis einem jahr
oder so nett war sonst freunde ich
brauche ich einfach schlafes tut mir
leid ihr findet als er beschreibung und
schön